deux étudiants prêts à tout pour trouver
une place en master hillman et rabat ont
entamé ce mardi une grève de la faim les
deux étudiants ont installé leur
campement à proximité des campus des
universités lyon 2 et lyon 3 pour
alerter sur leur situation
titulaire d'une licence de droit obtenue
en 2021 ils se sont vus refuser toute
leur candidature d'entrée en master
rabat réclame des explications j'ai
postulé aussi a également à l'université
lumière lyon 2 et qui m'a notifié dans
la refus d'admission assez surprenant
qui m'a choqué et qui m'a aussi humilié
pour le coup puisque dix affirment qu'en
fait j'ai pas fait de formation en droit
français alors que ce diplômé d'une
licence de droit
de l'université d'en face en fait et
donc je me demande sur quel fondement
ils se sont basés pour établir sur le
motif de refus et j'aimerais avoir des
explications qu'on m'a toujours pas
fourni hillman est également dans
l'impasse malgré la validation d'une
licence au printemps dernier dont
l'impossibilité de poursuivre ses études
la jeune étudiante se retrouve dans une
situation précaire quand s'inscrire à
l'université en première année on nous
avait dit qu'au bout de deux ans au
saillan on est fini et d'or ont fini
sans rien
jamais on nous à nous et ne nous a
jamais dit que durant un don pourrait
pas finir nos études et si à la fin on
prend quand même pas d'acheter comme une
d'or parce que malheureusement j'avais
dans une vision étudiante et quand j'ai
pas scolarisé va me territoire et du
coup je n'ai nulle part où aller à lyon
iii pour la rentrée 2021 plus de 35000
600 demandes ont été déposées pour
seulement 1000 places en master 1 de
droit face à un phénomène d'ampleur
nationale frédéric vidal la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur a annoncé
l'ouverture de quatre mille quatre cents
places supplémentaires bon les filières
en tension